dans notre langue de barbarie comme
mannequin c'est l'heure de la question
qu
la question
la question vaincu
et quoi que tu fasses l'amour est
partout où tu regardes on ça ouais ouais
ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais on y
est
le week end ou shopping
au flos milo surtout manchester et
liverpool
si jean solé le pas de calais chaud le
rideau va s'ouvrir
c'est votre show les loups c'est ce vol
seule la voix compte les looks
s'envisager des simulations que et puis
je les imagine habitants montent à
gueugnon comptera continue à tailler ça
ça toujours autour c'est en accord avec
le président de la république
[Rires]
17 heures
déjà fait le job est généralement
d'ailleurs que tu essayes mutation on a
été briefé pour en faire une
et c'est généralement un des ars en ce
qui nous concerne on vous pourriez
mettez qui bouge et ça c'est imiter
personne voulait didier deschamps
allaient beaucoup thales mais qui doit
se sont branchés sur haruna est décédé
mais bon je me donne deux animateurs qui
est en train sur la scène dans les gares
des dégâts et avait tout est ouvert
qu'est ce qui se passe on s'attelle à
nous la whey bayer pas de me dire ces
sujets très polémiques